oh hi over the last seven days nintendo
released the wii u and activision
brought out call of duty black ops 2 so
I understand if you don't really feel
like spending any more money on video
games this week in fact I understand if
you don't have any time even watch this
video actually that's that's not true if
you're not watching this video right now
you're dead to me but the point is it's
not yet time for your wallet to go on
extended hiatus there are still more
games coming out this week as we head
into Thanksgiving and here are some of
the big ones on Tuesday November 20 sony
releases PlayStation all-stars battle
royale may be one of the biggest
rip-offs in video game history but hey
it's been quite a while since nintendo
released a new super smash brothers so
if you want a fighting game that
combines characters from oly different
series into one big pot of mystery stew
you've got no other choice play is
Parappa the rapper and punch kratos from
God of War in the face or play is right
in from metal gear solid and fry your
enemies to death there haven't actually
been any reviews of this yet so it's
tough to say whether you should jump on
PlayStation all-stars but if you buy the
PlayStation 3 versions and includes for
free a download code for the portable
PlayStation Vita one that's a great deal
also on Tuesday agent 47 makes his
return in hitman absolution for
playstation 3 xbox 360 and PC this time
you'll be able to conduct assassinations
in many different ways want to rig up a
car to explode and then lure your target
over to it by setting off the alarm if
that's boring maybe you could poison
this food instead or just be simple
shoot them in the head and then run away
and all the confusion it's all up to you
but you know what forget all of that
everybody knows the biggest game of this
week is the long-awaited final climactic
episode of the walking dead Telltale
Games point-and-click adventure version
of the hit comic book and TV series has
been one of the most popular games of
the year and we've been following the
life-or-death journey of its main
characters Lee and Clementine through
four episodes that have been released so
far every player has made a number of
different decisions that have impacted
how their games play out and on November
21st it all ends well our heroes escape
the zombies will you be able to protect
Clementine from becoming one we're about
to find out so if you find yourself
sitting around the Thanksgiving table
this Thursday worried that the turkey is
going to come back to life thank the
walking dead now we here at game life
also feel that we deserve a little bit
of a holiday break so we will see you in
two weeks